hey guys Ryan right here and Jerry here
and guess what it's 2015 it is the year
that was supposed to have Batman vs
Superman but not this year anymore but
2016 I heard we wanted to say happy new
year to all the subscribers out there
and if you're new to the channel [ __ ]
welcome your ass in here spread it open
so we can inspect make sure you're not
carrying any illegal substances haha
search party just good mental image of a
bunch of people with flashlights like
inspecting one person to see if they're
covered in illegal substances now this
video is gonna be just strictly saying
how awesome the real rejects are really
we started this year off like 1700
subscribers and now it has 59,000 which
means we're just awesome good going and
I give all the credit to us that's where
the credit is really do because really
we just have a bunch of dummy accounts
and watch your own videos yeah I have
bought all these subscribers accounts
man yeah we have a lot of computer a lot
of servers work I've spent thousands of
dollars paying myself yeah egg money it
comes right back yet to profit it is
really tough business I break even
constantly but no seriously I know you
guys are actually real and it makes
sense that you're real real to ease get
it film reels were going baby don't make
noise when Jerry and Ryan are filming
that's the rule that's what I wrote down
on the whiteboard don't disobey the
whiteboards okay cuz now she's like
she's like a part of it she's like the
ghost of New Year's yet to be today okay
baby it's okay you're here in or what
the whiteboard says make more noise
thank you I've a donut to the partner
it's like annoying baby find an equal
amount of noise making two non noise
making that you can make you look like a
little worried but half annoyed also
half amused like that's her all the time
like a like a where's the end after that
that's I hear that question like every
hour here this video where is just
kidding so some changes that we're gonna
be making on this year
you guys suggest i will take some of
them into consideration real rejects
cooking show curry / yes artisan craft
show real rejects auto mechanic show
should have a makeup vlog show yeah make
you watch from [ __ ] makeover or you
can do suggestions that make sense yeah
I'm just I don't know that's why I'm not
a charge yeah no yeah it's okay Jay
b.r.j pair today they are good Jay berry
berry bad there Jay Baer you don't you
you won't do do you do you and you do
you the best you can do so a couple of
changes are going to happen 2015 reasons
to see is gonna become a podcast show
because we honestly feel we can give
better opinions when we can just walk
around a room and have a mic on yeah
just being honest just being honest what
do you want better quality or to see us
plus it's a different four minutes like
maybe you want to listen to the shizz in
the car yeah get it get a downloader and
illegally download these youtube video
you wanna Mabley maybe maybe you'd like
to city your computer watch a five
minute review maybe you'd like to cruise
around with a 25 minute exactly boom I'm
gonna try we're gonna try to reply a
little bit more that's a bold statement
a big aspiration if I will do my best so
either like the comment or reply back
nah is that fair feels like a fair that
seems unfair right I'm gonna try but a
try sometimes it never they a lot come
in and yeah just this the popularity of
this channel is [ __ ] insane give us
suggestions of what do you want to see
more of yes I know there's more trailers
we can review sure but like we're
talking like kinds of contents like yeah
is there a kind of video or are kind of
thing that we don't currently do or like
what do we not do enough of like do you
want to see more movie reviews you want
to see Jerry do more indie reviews do
you want more vlogs doing sketches you
want more vines do you want more sour
patch sour pass finds it oh noes red
runs I'm sorry
screw this whole thing up but I can't
can't do anyway 2015 is gonna rock Chris
Pratt's gonna be in Jurassic world you
know it's gonna be good sorry I have
parks and rec I'm a whole thing about a
Jurassic world right now I mean who
convinced those people to donate money
to the like who who was good enough at
their job to be like okay listen I know
a lot of people died the last time we
tried this and cities were utterly
destroyed lives were ruined but that's
not gonna happen soon so you should
donate money does so we can bring this
back to life because what could possibly
do it will get even bigger dinosaurs
yeah well Emily me worrying you and say
you can't predict whether this is a
totally great idea guys we have clearly
learned nothing from the past huh happy
new year happy new year 2015 20 2015
2015 Charlie Sheen duh winning